dr. Peterson do you have suggestions for
how to make a schedule that doesn't make
you a tyrant I've watched your previous
videos but I'm struggling to make a
weekly schedule that is productive hey
Joshua start by making a weekly schedule
that you want really like imagine that
you're designing your schedule so that
you can have the life you want just
start with that like and be easy on
yourself to begin with you know you'll
get better at it you can add more
responsibilities as you as you practice
so so start by just scheduling in a few
things that you'd like to do and then
load it up over time but remember like
get get your attitude right I'm using
this schedule so that I can have the
days and the weeks and the months that
would make my life that would optimize
my life right not so that I should do
what I need to get done I mean obviously
that's necessary but that's not the
right goal